now that it's here it will never let you
go on October 28th Sony Pictures
unveiled the first trailer for the
upcoming grudge reboot an r-rated
refresh of the 2004 supernatural horror
film of the same name which itself was
an American remake of the 2002 Japanese
horror classic Jew owned like the 2004
version of The Grudge and the film it
was inspired by director Nicholas
Pesci's reboot of the property roots
itself in the same blood chilling curse
when someone dies in the grip of rage
and entity forms killing everyone who
comes in contact with it and passing on
the grudge in an endless cycle that said
it should come as no surprise that the
first trailer for the reboot of The
Grudge features several references to
the films that came before it these are
the most important details in The Grudge
reboot trailer early on in the trailer
for the grudge reboot we watched real
estate agents Peter Spencer enter the
house he and his wife are selling head
upstairs and leaned down to look at the
bathtub mysteriously filled with jet
black water as he brings his face closer
to the tub a pair of hands break the
surface of the water and grab the sides
of Peters head what the heck just
happened there obviously the entity or
entities living within the house aren't
afraid to make their existence known and
will lash out in any way they can
it's also clear that one of the ghosts
is taking hold in the same location
where a supernatural beast present in
The Grudge liked to hide out the
bathroom specifically it was Toshio the
dead son of Tokyo psyche who killed his
wife kaya chol after discovering she was
in love with another man in the American
version of the film's Tokyo drowned
young Toshio in the bathtub
[Music]
The Grudge reboot director Nicolas Peche
previously explained to IGN that the
drowning motif quote keeps coming back
throughout the new film given that quote
the nature of the bathtub is that part
of the initial crime that started this
all was a drowning but is the evil
spirit shown in the bathtub within the
first Grudge reboot trailer actually
Toshio or is it another entity entirely
Pesche noted this time to Collider that
The Grudge reboot takes place at a
slightly different time than the other
flicks so there's a chance that the body
in the bathtub is indeed Toshio who may
have resurfaced in a new location to
continue haunting the innocence pair
that information with the fact that the
trailer also includes a shot of what
appears to be a ghostly being peeking
over the edge of the bathtub and it
looks like toshio will make a grisly
comeback in the new grudge movie on the
subject of horrifying spirits from The
Grudge franchise it looks as though
Toshio slain mother Keuchel also appears
in the trailer for the flick there's a
moment that shows a character named
Fiona walking in broad daylight unaware
that a ghost is behind her with her
white skin black hair draped over her
face and dropped open mouth the spirit
bears a striking resemblance to Keiko
whose presence is also felt later in the
trailer and we see a body tumbling down
the center of a stairwell both fans of
jus owned the grudge and the grudge
alike as well as people who have never
seen the film's before will know that
kaya Cole has a strong connection to
stairs she famously crawled down them in
the most nightmarish of manners as she
was closing in on one of her victims
maybe she's the one who threw the body
down the stairwell or perhaps her
appearance caused the person to leap to
their death Pesche has confirmed that
the curse happening in the u.s. is quote
connected to the one in Japan and teased
that it had been brought to the country
like a malignant disease Pesche told IGN
The Grudge is kind of like a virus it
spreads and is contagious so much of
what we wanted to do with this movie is
show that yes you know very well what's
been happening in Japan but what you
don't realize is this is happening in
other places too and it's not just
contained to this one house in Japan
it's here and it's here
and it's here and it's everywhere at
several points in the footage including
the pre-roll singer we see a gray-haired
woman on the brink of insanity she's
first shown laughing maniacally in a
kitchen with blood running down her chin
and neck she then pops up looking less
human than before with her hands
blackened and curled up her eyes sunken
in and her mouth dropped open in a
pained yell the character may be a new
one in the grudge universe but the
actress who plays her has been at the
horror game for decades now she's lin
shaye a bona fide scream queen who has
appeared in films like a Nightmare on
Elm Street critters the Ouija movies and
perhaps most famously insidious this
time around Shaye plays the creepy
cackling woman named faith matheson
who's clearly affected by the grudge in
some way and may even be revealed as the
original owner of the house where the
curse has taken hold did she bring the
grudge to the states from Japan is she
the woman who committed the killing in
the grudged home
we suspect faith will be a major player
in the upcoming movie if this first
trailer didn't scare you away
catch the grudge in theaters on January
3rd 2020 check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite horror movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the belt so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]